- I'm back
in sunny Southern California
in Simi Valley
at my home forge,
and, um, this is
where the magic happens.
[upbeat music]
Most of this is armor shop,
but I have all the tools
for making blades
and weapons.
When I make a knife, I use
maybe two or three hammers,
not very many.
When I make armor, I could use
30 or 40 different hammers,
and many different shapes
for stakes.
Uh, all of my armor work
is done hot
using a rosebud torch.
These are my two proudest
prized possessions,
and they don't really have
any real value,
but both of these were used in
making the Statue of Liberty.
And that holds
a pretty special part,
um, for me, being American.
♪ ♪
- Hi, I'm Ryan Weaver,
and this is my shop.
Uh, this is kind of
my heating/forging center.
Uh, this is actually
a propane...
uh, forge.
This is my major,
uh, armor-working station.
and this is just
a selection of the stakes.
As an armorer,
I use a lot of different stakes
to make
a lot of different shapes
to do all sorts
of different stuff.
This is my gas saver,
which these things
are lifesavers.
If you're going
to get into doing armor
or anything like that,
ah, man, it's just--
total game changer.
- I have a background
in medieval martial arts.
Armored combat,
it's my favorite thing
in the world to do.
I'm Nicholas.
- I'm Dave.
- And we're gonna hit each
other in the head with sticks.
- For fun.
[laughs]
[rock music]
- And we do tournaments
and melees...
from one-on-one
to 1,000 guys on each side.
It's fun and you get
to hit your friends
as hard as you can,
and then go have a beer
with them afterwards.
[both exhale, armor clanging]
- That's all you get.
- That was awesome, Dave.
- I'm tired.
- 2012,
I was part of
the first U.S. team
to fight internationally
in full-contact
steel fighting.
In order to make sure I had
a steady flow
of sparring partners,
I ended up making
a lot of armor.
The problem with doing
full-contact steel combat,
is that, first, it--
it's hard on armor,
and so there's a constant need
to repair and replenish.
And it's also hard
on sparring partners.
So there's, again, a constant
need to repair and replenish.
[dramatic music]